wir haben andere die augen verbunden und
sind bei dir zu einem
verkehrsübungsplatz gefahren ohne dass
sie davon wusste
ja sandra du hast du schon richtig
erraten ich bin mit dir heute auf einen
verkehrsübungsplatz gefahren um einfach
mal zu gucken wie du nicht so im
straßenverkehr schlägt wir haben dass er
so ein bisschen als running gag in
unserem podcast das zurzeit 50 anderen
führerschein macht und daher kann es
jetzt mal zeigen was du so gelernt hast
dank an der stelle an firat der uns ein
auto heute zur verfügung stellt kannst
du kurz mal oberschenkel rechtskraft
[Musik]
also sagen wir sitzen im auto
zuallererst sind wir angeschnallt alle
ja du musst das selber dabei fahren auch
kontrollieren ja ich war traurig was
macht man als erstes wenn man im auto
jetzt die spiegel haben stein gestellt
oder auffällig gekommen als allererstes
macht man den motor an
jetzt schon na ja also wir wollen da los
nehmen sie jetzt nicht mehr betätigen
würde wagen rollen
doch wie auch immer ich mag ich dabei
schmerzen sondern wir sind nicht mal
losgefahren deutschland schmerzen wir
sind in greift das wird uns auch vorne
angezeigt und jetzt ganz langsam an die
bremse loslassen sandra
20 sekunden später erfahren gerade 7 km
h das ist sicher schrittgeschwindigkeit
an die sehr sehr gut jetzt einfach
fahren wir mal hier im kreis hier vorne
links machen wir jetzt warum ich so
versichern ich bin nicht sicher ist wie
viele leute soll ich was sagen das
lenkrad ist an meinem bauch ich glaube
ihnen sofern das auto
ich glaube das wort zuviel kamen kam
rasch so sandra wir sehen jetzt da vorne
bereits ein schild das stets top drauf
da fahren wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen hier mal was zeigen
dass hier ist der aachener war ja meine
lieben freunde verkehrsübungsplatzes
auch super intakt noch den ganzen
umgefallen den schildern sondern wir
fahren jetzt gerade sage und schreibe 17
kamen haben kannst jetzt mal
beschleunigen auf 30 km/h wir haben eine
freie strecke vor uns aber immer auch
acht geben auf die schlaglöcher hat und
dass der herr vieler tier
aufpasste jetzt sehen wir schon hier ist
eine pfütze müssen wir ganz ganz langsam
durchfahren
[Musik]
sei jetzt links rum aber blinker setzen
klinker ich kann doch nicht an die play
decken ja aber wir haben ja auch andere
autos wieder mit uns
fragt wo ist ein klick am 16 wir halten
jetzt mal hier vorne an
wir fahren jetzt noch 20 es regnet nicht
sondern
und jetzt habe ich den blick angemacht
euro kann man jetzt auch kurz über den
kleinen hügel drüber und dann bekommst
du mal langsam jetzt hier vor der weißen
linie auf die aus dem steht perfekt das
war die weiße linie aber gut sandra wir
stehen hier jetzt erst mal du machst
jetzt deinen linken fuß auf der bremse
da hast du recht wird komplett durch
drücken damit die launch control machen
wir machen jetzt mal eine kleine aufgabe
ist ja was mich stresst hier zu viele
automobile
das war es jetzt mal eine kleine aufgabe
mit
dann nicht video es ist bisher wirklich
schon relativ gut ich hätte wirklich
nicht gedacht dass du dich so wie das
schicksal es gibt auch viele leute die
angst davor haben dass erst noch einfach
angst
aber ich bin halt naturtalent und einem
was ich tue machen jetzt trotzdem erst
mal ein kleines quiz mit ihr wo ist die
hupe
[Musik]
lasse die hupe für fünf sekunden lang
gedrückt
[Musik]
wenn man mir ist ein bisschen warm
kannst du die kinder lage vielleicht ein
bisschen kühler stellen
für rath ich finde angenehm und alle
müssen sich nach dem fahrer richten also
die fresse du kannst jetzt weiter fragen
du fährst jetzt mal bitte dahin zu dem
stoppschild
wie geht das noch mal leute also wie
viele fehler wir kriegen hier
ist eine cook noch wasser ja so sander
wir wollen jetzt hier mit
7 km h schleichen wir gerade auf das
stoppschild zu
so beschreibt nicht mehr wenn man
komplett zum stillstand gekommen ist was
zählt man da
nur noch staunen deutschland
du kannst dir als faustregel merken wenn
du ein stopp schild sieht fährst du four
bis zur durchgezogenen linie von wänden
stillstand gekommen ist sagt du dir im
kopf 21 22 und dann fährst du weiter
während dieser zeit guckst du dich ein
bisschen dann auch um und so weil einem
stoppschild weiß man da sind gefahren
schlangen
wir werden hier gerade überholt kann das
seitenruder kommt ein fettes automobil
ich habe angst dass uns super 21 22 23
bis nach 22 leute
[Musik]
ich kenne jemanden zusammen auf die
bremse los
die jetzt auf mich los kommst und kann
sagen ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie im
theater aber das kaputt gemacht mit
einer aussage die alles gut
ist dass wir auf setzen aber ich gebe
mein bester ist ich habe schlagt euch ja
schon gut und fahren wo das kann man
auch ein nur elektromobil führerschein
machen also nur auf wie heißt das
nochmals automatik automatica aber das
soll keine schaltwegen ja juckt mich
nicht so sondern was ich ganz ehrlich
sagen muss diese ingo bohg vor meinem
gesicht
wir haben jetzt ein kleines problem und
zwar ist hinter uns ein auto das kannst
du auch im rückspiegel und jetzt haben
wir auch noch einen smart hinter uns
also zwei karosserie die hinter uns
warten die da vorne und lasst uns auch
stichwort ich glaube es ist an der zeit
ist und einen ganz kleinen tick
schneller vielleicht zu 70 80 km h nein
falls einmal bis zum ende von der straße
hier vorne
nicht lange schuldig da kann man einfach
nicht
tatsächlich gerade sehr sehr weit rechts
aber ja aber ich musste ein schlagloch
gefahren jetzt hier rechts sonder einmal
kurz hier noch rechts blinken perfekt
den namen vergessen ist egal wir fahren
jetzt einfach
wir können ihnen lang und jetzt einmal
um den see reise war nichts luca
warum nicht jetzt habe ich hier so ein
chrysler da will ich dass du einmal
außen rum laufen von der geschicht was
halt die fresse ich kann das nicht wir
fahren einfach nur im kreis sandra
außerhalb sie sind jetzt in einer
kreis und das schlagloch fakten
und jetzt
du kannst jetzt hier einfach mal das
auto abstellen also die bremse ganz toll
betätigen perfekt jetzt das auto
ausstellen
perfekt p und jetzt den knopf drücken
sehr gut jetzt noch die handbremse
einlegen
erste bremse
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch ich möchte ihnen
hiermit feierlich überreichte ihnen ist
hier mit ihren führerschein
lassen daumen hoch unter video da wenn
es euch gefallen hat abonniert main
kanal wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt
und klickt auf die glocke
einmal
können sich jetzt noch hier angucken wie
sander und ich den führerschein test im
internet gemacht haben und hier könnt
ihr auch noch einen kanal abonnieren
wenn ihr zweiten teil haben wollt dann
schreibt sie die kommentare
und wir
müssen jetzt noch